so you're reading all kinds of reports
about ukrainian citizens taking up arms
being given arms to fend off russian
invaders politicians apparently are
doing the same one of them is ukrainian
member of parliament
his name is sevilla tislavurash and he
joins us tonight mr ash thanks so much
uh for joining us so
i don't know if you can hear me um but
if you can are are you personally taking
up arms to repel the invaders
the reality is we are in kiev we are
being sieged right now and this is the
capital of the largest european state
that is basically under the full-scale
invasion of russia that is trying to
destroy it annihilate it and take it
over in every single way the point here
there is no citizen that is not thinking
about what he will do when russia russia
tries to take over the city and those
millions of people in this town are
taking up arms taking up any instrument
they can try and resist
have you seen um speaking for yourself
have you seen russian forces within the
city
yes we have seen russian forces there
have been skirmishes with various mature
groups they've been trying to get into
city we are capturing their pows by the
hundreds all over ukraine now as far as
key is concerned we have them moving
from the north
trying through the east uh they are
trying to
encircle the city basically the south
and west is mostly open and again we are
trying to keep it that way by taking
over taking back towns
in the in the west of kiev and basically
i've been those front lines and
that's the point of trying to basically
keep our city
us
ah
are you do you plan to stay
very much so our president is very near
where i'm standing right now uh hope the
government is staying in kiev it is our
capital city we aren't going to just
give it up again this is our country and
we don't want uh to allow putin's uh
illusions so grandeur destroy our dreams
of independence of liberty
we will fight for that
has there been a lot of fighting in say
the neighborhoods around kiev yes
yes yes there have been lots of fighting
in the north of kiev they got in with a
very big column to that they are trying
to move through chernobyl endangering
all of europe by taking over the planet
and trying to again uh basically spin it
off out of control and moving through
that lot of heavy machinery artillery
and uh infantry and basically they even
they got into north of kiev and citizen
citizens there basically rallied around
the attempt to just destroy them and
they had pushed them out of the city
basically this the fighting right now is
what heaviest around the city is it
limits we are just uh facing various
sub-mature groups that we can push back
amazing well godspeed good luck to you
uh as you do thank you tucker hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else